bien m'écouter moi j'avais demandé une
responsabilité aux républicains pas un
travail mais pas de chance merci merci à
lui que je pense que chacun était
absolument passionné par ce que tu as
dit merci de l'avoir dit merci d'avoir
intégré tout cela à nos à nos réflexions
et puis surtout à d'avoir montré que le
travail est évidemment quelque chose
d'indispensable
et c'est évidemment là la cause de
toutes les réformes que nous devons
mener si nous voulons réconcilier la
france avec notre propre nation
merci à toi alors nous allons maintenant
nous allons entamer la troisième table
ronde je prends mes notes parce que je
ne sais plus qui joue appelé voilà je ne
me trompe pas dans cette troisième table
ronde
on va aborder les sujets de relation
avec notamment l'administration le juge
et pour en parler je demande donc à
christian brémond qui est avocat et qui
va nous rejoindre merci d'être là jean
bernard falco et jean persenda
jean-bernard felco et président de paris
een groupe qui est un groupe hôtelier et
j'en perds soda et président directeur
général de se faire et ça ce sont deux
patrons de sociétés ou d'entreprise
qu'on recherche souvent ce sont les
hôtes et y des entreprises ii dite de
taille intermédiaire qui en réalité sont
déjà de taille importante
la taille intermédiaire c'est évidemment
une taille importante et évidemment ils
sont confrontés chaque jour aux
questions de réformes et d'application
du droit du travail difficultés
d'application du droit du travail
et puis bien évidemment également de
relations avec l'administration qui gère
cela bernard gérard et député du nord et
bernard a écrit un rapport tout à fait
intéressant et passionnant avec un sujet
qui est pas totalement un ex par rapport
au sujet qui nous occupe ce matin c'est
le rapport avec l'urssaf et puis annie
genevard mme qui est qui et qui est pas
là voilà donc annie genevard qui n'est
pas là et qui nous parlera en n'étant
pas là du rsi puisque annie a travaillé
notamment dans un groupe ii d'un groupe
concernant le
le rsi juste avant de de commencer et en
attendant éventuellement annie je
souhaitais peut-être juste faire un tout
petit point et nicolas sarkozy viendra
tout à l'heure non pas synthétiser nos
travaux mais aussi amener les idées qui
ont été aujourd'hui me mis sur la table
d'abord la réforme du code du travail
c'est aussi d'aborder toutes les
questions de toutes les formes du
travail réforme et toutes les formes du
travail et je pense que notamment luc
ferry l'a très bien dit tout à l'heure
puisqu'il a évoqué le mot qu'on évoque
aujourd'hui sans arrêt c'est à dire
libéralisation ça veut dire tout
simplement des relations du travail qui
changent en fonction de la production
d'un trail produits qui changent de
nature le numérique change la nature du
travail les services ne sont pas rendus
de la même manière même si évidemment
continuera à produire des biens il ya
bien un moment donné où les choses
deviennent réelles et pas uniquement
virtuelle mais à un moment donné aussi
où le service devient de plus en plus
non plus annexes mais quelque chose de
très important dans le domaine de la
production industrielle mais nos
entrepreneurs l'ont déjà dit à plusieurs
plusieurs reprises donc le code du
travail doit viser l'ensemble des formes
de travail et le code du travail tels
que il a été tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
elle rédige et vous avez ici un code du
travail j'ai fait un peu de musculation
donc je soulève mais je vais
immédiatement leur poser ce code du
travail il
il a été largement fait pour le travail
classique pour le travail au fond on
arrive le matin on repart le soir on est
dans une entreprise on pointe
ça ne veut pas dire que cette forme de
travail et est terminée qu'il n'y a plus
ce type de travail aujourd'hui en france
au contraire il est le plus répandu et
que c'est essentiellement le travail
salarié
mais ça veut dire aussi que il faut que
le code du travail puisse donner un
certain nombre de droits fondamentaux
dire ce que la nation de demande ou and
men et comment la nation protège toutes
les formes du travail selon des règles
fondamentales qui forment notre pacte
social
si au fond ça qui est très très
important la protection c'est pas la
protection de tous les jours c'est pas
la protection de l'employé contre son
employeur c'est la production de lundi
but contre les abus ou contre
l'impossibilité en réalité d'être ce
qu'il doit être ou 21e siècle dans une
société française extrêmement murs
notamment sur les droits fondamentaux
qui sont les noms les nôtres en temps en
temps comme ou en tant que femme
deuxième point il faut pas empêcher le
code du travail pardon empêche il
empêche le travail et c'est quelque
chose qui était très près 10 par nos
économistes a été dit par les
économistes qui se sont succédé d'autres
l'ont dit de droite ou de gauche
d'ailleurs au fond c'est un constat
c'est pas un plaidoyer idéologique
le code du travail à force de règlement
test de réglementer à force de
rigidifier à force de se structurer en
fait ils empêchent tout simplement un
moment donné d'embauché
quand on empêche de licenciés on empêche
aussi d'embaucher et il faut pas se
méprendre ce sont pas des formules on
n'a évidemment pas du tout envie que
tout travailleur soit licencié pour
n'importe quelle raison personne ne dit
cela et je pense qu'aucun chef
d'entreprise n'a envie de le faire donc
il faut bien évidemment faire en sorte
que en permettant de débaucher en
fonction d'un certain nombre de raisons
de motifs évidemment réel au sérieux
mais en étendant les motifs de
licenciement en faisant en sorte qu'il
soit plus souple moins interprété par la
jurisprudence ça permette de l'autre
côté de se dire que lorsqu'on a besoin
d'un salarié nouveau n'hésite pas à
prendre ce salarié nous évidemment ça
fait baisser aussi la dichotomie la
dualité du marché du travail entre cdd
et cdi l'idée c'est pas uniquement le
contrat unique c'est au fond qui est
bonne moins en moins de cdd parce qu'on
a de moins en moins besoin de cdd le cdh
est une façon de répondre au contraire à
la rigidité du du contrat à durée
indéterminée donc du droit du travail
le troisième point qui a été évoquée
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est la durée du
travail il j'entendais madame beck est
quelque part voilà qui a fait un exposé
tout à fait remarquable qui disait et
d'autres l'ont dit franck morel aussi
qu'ils ont dit mais il faut pas que il
faut pas qu'il y ait des dérogations on
peut pas avoir une loi au fond vous vous
laissez vos lois puis après vous déroger
la dérogation n'est pas une bonne chose
je ne pense pas qu'il faille proposer
des dérogations à tous avec des lois
extrêmement rigide et puis des
dérogations
il faut que l'exception soit la loi
quand on parle d'accord d'entreprise
c'est parce que
exception doit être la loi la règle
c'est l'accord d'entreprise et la loi
doit se doit ce doit être modifié en
fonction de cela et lorsqu'on parle des
35 heures l'exception sera les 35 heures
la règle c'est la négociation dans
l'entreprise sur le temps de travail
donc la liberté de négocier le temps de
travail en fonction de l'entreprise de
ses comptes agences de ces de sa culture
de ses marchés de sa capacité à chercher
des clients à l'étranger ou à côté de
chez elle
enfin bref de ce qui fait sa spécificité
donc la réforme du temps de travail que
l'on peut être amené à proposer c'est au
fond la fin des 35 heures la liberté
pour l'entreprise
et puis bien évidemment si l'entreprise
se met pas d'accord il ya une référence
une valeur de substitution ou
supplétives qui est qui et qui est
clairement défini par la loi
et puis le contrat c'est évidemment
pouvoir se séparer de deux de salariés
mais de façon plus claire plus sain plus
souple tout en préservant les droits des
salariés gelé évoqué enfin sur les 1 les
instances les institutions
représentatives du personnel
mais je pense que là aussi il faut être
très très clair il faut les syndicats il
faut des syndicats forts et ses
syndicats forts au contraire
apparaissent à ce moment là comme des
interlocuteurs sérieux solide pour faire
évoluer l'entreprise en lien avec
évidemment l'employeur puis plus
généralement de temps en temps sur des
négociations nationales mais on va il
faut aussi les institutions
représentatives du personnel qui
représente le personnel donc la
démocratie sociale elle doit jouer en
plein et on voit bien que la démocratie
politique elle est peut-être affaibli et
que les trois dernières années qu'on a
vécu en ont contribué à l'affaiblir bien
enfin on voit bien aussi que la
démocratie sociale c'est plus qu'un mot
c'est plus qu'un leurre elle n'existe
pas elle existe au sein de l'entreprise
parce qu'on dialogue mais ça manque
singulièrement de liberté et de
simplification et on a proposé vous avez
proposé tout à l'heure un certain nombre
de simplification il faudra qu'on
tranche sur ces simplifications
voilà je voulais faire un tout petit un
tout petit point avant de céder la
parole à nos nos interlocuteurs je
voudrais peut-être demander à commence
il faut toujours commencer par un avocat
donc par par christian bresson c'est pas
mon expérience je vous rassure et
christian brémond pourrait peut-être
évoquer avec eux avec nous ce qui a
souvent été indiqué comme une houe font
une contrainte ou quelque chose qui
insécurise leaf les chefs d'entreprise
ce et c'est là le rôle du juge dans dans
le droit social
aujourd'hui qui a pris une part
importante ce code du travail c'est 20%
que je reste prudent 20% le
jurisprudence
quand on dit qu'on va faire un code à 50
pages où 150 pages pourquoi pas mais au
fond c'est pas tellement le sujet car ça
veut dire qu'à ce nom là on donne plus
de pouvoir encore au juge et donc moins
de pouvoirs à la légitimité et luttes
démocratiques ou à la légitimité de la
démocratie sociale il faut évidemment un
juge
nul ne peut penser le contraire mais
encore faut-il que son rôle soit
clairement définie